[Music]
canapé way all right guys we are live at
drag con la with the one the only high E
it's Alaska hi how are you what's your
drag con so far I'm living look at this
this is turn it's turn to mark on stage
performing to carly rae jepsen right now
we're out the corner of Chung pop and
porkchop way we've got a little crowd
gathered here this is a kind of one of
few chances where you can really
interact with everybody truly this is a
great location this is prime real estate
I'm real estate how are you renting or
selling or I think we're borrowing yeah
where we're squatting let's talk about
your vagina that just dropped yeah
record called vagina little record yeah
surprised the world hold a pee on say Oh
fully no mostly it was just like I don't
know we huh
we've been working on the music for a
while I was like just do it I don't want
to do all the like it's coming are you
ready
it's gonna come I hate that if I see the
thing is out I want to click it I want
it now
so we did it so it's out for the world
to get yeah perfectly timed with Drakon
what not a vibe of the new music it's
really fun it's like classic Alaska it's
like some songs are about like getting
wasted and getting thrown under
nightclubs some songs are about like
getting pissed on and like I'll find
that is some songs are like serious and
like women deserve not to have their
bodies regulated by the law and by man
like them so we're covering everything
the whole gay man the whole spectrum
why why name the record vagina
um well my first album was called anus
and so moving up through the chakra
systems of the body the next one is the
genitals and dicks get enough attention
so its vagina alright obviously people
geeked out about seeing you here at
Drakon do geeked out about seeing
anybody here I um haven't spotted RuPaul
yeah and I'm gonna lose my cm where
where is he right now I think in hiding
I want I will lose it when I see RuPaul
I can't wait
so even two times on TV with RuPaul
gotten to interact with them you still
have that kind of pinch me moly
starstruck Wow starstruck yeah alright
this is kind of the big party before the
season 11 finale airs on Thursday on vhy
I know who's it gonna be who are you
rooting for honestly II be oddly eyes I
see amazing things in her drag that
remind me of when I started drag and
that sort of like fresh perspective that
she has is really like appealing I
really like her and you know that's no
shades of the other girls because I
think they're really amazing I just
think this is Evie's year yeah
definitely she stands out from that pack
yeah totally and she does she reminds me
a lot of you and of the Sharon's of the
world who brings something different
I'm honored for that comparison because
she's really talented and really a
sweetheart and she's a young person with
a really good head on her shoulders
alright you want to get to know Alaska a
little better than we've ever met a last
ever so we're gonna play a QA with you
ah how do you you treat yourself what
like if you're gonna have a treat
yourself day just a day where you can do
whatever the hell you want I lay out in
my backyard which is not a yard it's
like a little sliver of where I get
sunlight in the morning I lay out there
and I bake myself like I'm so tan right
now are very so tan I love that they're
glowing all right what is your go-to
indulgence
um indulgence tea what I have with me
right now brought some yeah don't
selling I need to live like I won't I
can't go do drag unless there's tea okay
that's the Alaska live I sponsor me guys
what's the craziest fan encounter you've
ever had I'm always blown away with the
tattoos there's this one fan named Teddy
in England and he came to one of my
shows years ago and he said sign my bum
I'm gonna get it tattooed I was like
okay sure whatever and still to this day
he comes to my shows and it's still
there it's tattooed on the bomb when
you're here at drag Con people come
dressed as you is that weird or cool how
would you describe I love it I love
Alaska impersonators and it's really
easy you can pretty much get an Alaska
costume at like CBS you know sometimes
you can do that duct tape saran wrap
call it a night all right what is your
ideal night out or night in my ideal
night in is ordering food and GrubHub
and watching I'm really into watching
veep right now okay that's like my
favorite show right now ended I know and
I started it over cuz I was like I can't
take this show whole of not having it
anymore so yeah I started from the
beginning okay yeah I love people what
is your go-to dance song um RuPaul call
me mother cow cow I don't know a single
word but it's a good but you know that
part which is the most important part
yeah and in a slow part whoa
[Music]
there is still a lot of drag Khan left
this weekend what are you looking
forward to from the next day and a half
I just like meeting the kids like I like
sitting in my well-lit little box and
just the kids get to come it they're so
excited this is like Disneyland yeah
like they love that so it's it's really
fun meeting the kids yeah I love that
there are so many kids here cuz it's
yeah it's a family affair right really
is there's a whole kid zone over there
that way it's a family function yes when
you see that you can kind of see how far
the world is coming I know when you look
around and see families are coming out
and saying yeah celebrate this yeah
could you imagine if when we were kids
there's dad oh I get imagine no I
my brain has miss miss but I can try it
alright well thank you so much for
stopping by ichi live always be you
vagina is out on all platforms right now
right is yeah link in my bio yes got at
alright so that's all we're gonna let
elastin go back to her boots meter fans
and we're gonna see what's happening out
on the floor
okay so thank you for talking with me oh
yeah bye
[Music]